ma con quale virilità me lo stai dicendo
zio è un segno di matrimonio ma che
cazzo succede doppiare a calci il tizio
questa era fottutamente geniale geniale
veda tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
video sono vari geni ed oggi siamo
tornati su eravamo rimasti ragazzi che
avevo finito il capitolo 1 cioè questo
qui dove ero piccolo e possiamo iniziare
col capitolo ii dove sono meno piccolo
va bene e i livelli dove di scelgo qua a
questo a sono i tasti dell'ascensore
bellissimo primo piano tra in un
castello abbandonato ragazzi mac pixar
salviamo la situazione non ho capito
buongiorno signora regina mi scusi
signor giullare sono tutte le mutandine
signor giullare e non la volevo dare a
lui in una lenta veramente veramente ce
l'ho fatta ragazzi ok non so come ma la
prima l'ho già risolta e siamo partiti
da dio mai successo perché c'è
supermario steso su una brandina
tutte domande che non avranno mai
risposta ragazzi però io le tocco le
bocce
anzi tocco lui non è servito a niente ma
vabbè ci ho provato importante questi
ragazzi se riesco a farne tre di fila mi
manda in un bonus non avete visto
l'altra volta giorno che cosa è successo
qui perché c'è una bomba nucleare in
camera tua zio che cazzo di problemi c'è
il computer ho spento il computer bene
ho salvato la situazione sono state un
genio come ti sei trovato su un ponte
del genere spiega mi zio no io capirlo
non ho ciak
non lo so che ricorrente in soggiorno
non ho capito perché cos'è sta roba è
una bomba
tirana l'aveva con la bomba ho lanciato
la pac è giusto
e giusto che culo ragazzi due su quattro
è un record incredibile e ve lo dico
devo il trenino altre no
lo zucchero fiato lo zucchero lodo ha
sbagliato ma chi era bella voi non lo
sapete ragazzi ma in realtà ho vinto e
solo che vuole farmi credere che non sia
così mega satan voi del cazzo di
concerto è sarebbe un gruppo ama madonna
del cazzo fa a questo tizio c'è una
bomba per terra l'avesse esplode non se
ne accorge nessuno stanno ascoltando in
metal journal te la regalo tra infilò
nel q vabbè però non era male come
situazione cioè per carità son riuscito
a creare un nuovo look ma va ragazzi 2
su 6 che è già qualcosa perché ho fatto
anche 0 su 6 quindi va benissimo è la
tipa non è allora devo prendere questo
devo darlo a supermario sto picchiando
super mario con una bomba non era questo
che ci ho provato
questa è una casa nell'antartide
spiegami come mica come ci sei finito
qui allora la bomba la prendo
non è esattamente quello che volevo fare
però va bene alla gallina la gallina
sicuro la prendo e la metto sulla bomba
perfetto davvero a devo fare così sul
serio allora bomba tipo a terra il tipo
terra che è che devo fà ho preso tizio
lo butto fuori ma no ma cos'è vabbè dai
raga ma che cazzo è sta roba dov'è il
senso gioco non lo capisco c'è un
qualcosa che non capì dov'è la bomba mi
spiegate dove stava le detta bomba per
cortesia
eccola c'era il pagliaccio e ho capito
cosa ci devo fare niente non lo so ora
che non lo so perfetto ragazzi questa è
fatta per forza devo fa così non c'è
altro non posso fare altro
e perché questa stessa cosa non poteva
funzionare con super mario con la tizia
spiegamelo niente lega non c'e verso di
vivere nella vita ho spento a [ __ ]
credevo di avercela fatta ero convinto
che fosse così non era non era quello
adottato dal suo tizio quadrato e
profilato no lodare i fan perfetto ciò
fatta dovevo avere lo zucchero filato in
mano per dargli i palloncini perché non
potevo dargli e lì senza lo zucchero
filato ovvio devo fare qualcosa questo
tizio ragazzi che guardate come lo porta
come se fosse un oggetto bellissimo o
scassato il computer con tizio giusto
niente ora che non c'è verso non so cosa
devo fare ho provato il tizio sulla
bomba
[Musica]
se va bene che ho capito ma che gioco è
questo ma che cosa minchia mi son messo
a giocare ma spiegami il senso ma a chi
ma il creatore visto gioco marche cosa
si è calato prima di fa sta roba no
voglio capirlo non ha senso
ok questi li ho fatti perfetto passiamo
al secondo che voi ragazzi round li sto
facendo al contrario perché quello era
round tra queste due epic sa cosa devo
fare
leo disinnescare la miccia con un
canarino credo non stava buongiorno bene
è perfetta non è esattamente quello che
volevo fare prove mi spiace per il
canarino poverino non ne può niente lui
giorno c'è qualcuno che guarda tv c'è un
fucile spara al bambino col fucile un
bambino questo sbagliato perfetto come
non deve allo zoo addirittura ecco
questo non capace una siringa spiegami
lassini alla siringa sulla giraffa si è
giusto perfetto non ho capito niente
però va bene salve signor e devo
disinnescare una bomba e adesso me ne
vado subito tranquillo perfetto a casa
in mezzo alla foresta di notte chi cazzo
è questo apro la porta apro la finestra
di buttò fuori no ma che minchia ma
fammi fare qualcosa maledizione treno a
vapore regalo ce la faremo prima o poi
le non è possibile estintore l'estintore
ovviamente dovrei spegnere qui ho
buttato destinta o per niente come non
detto dove mi sa che ci devo buttare il
tizio là dentro va bene c'è qualcosa di
nascosto che non vedo tipo lo zerbino la
porta
tale notizia lo sa ding failed
caricamento fallito ha lanciato la bomba
sul televisore ci siamo salvati funziona
lo prendo e lo buttò fuori dalla
finestra giusto no lo butto fuori dalla
porta
c'è una bomba buongiorno
vabbè se va bene a lui ragazzi non è un
problema questo ecco il treno credo di
averla trovata questo qua sicuro mi
butto giù io mi butto dentro è un
[ __ ] genio ma come non ci sono
arrivato primo
la possiamo fare giusto questa credo di
avere livello bonus più questa qui
sarebbero tre credo che ci sia qualcosa
qua dentro tipo ecco affanculo cielo
quasi maledizione non era quello niente
ragazzo pensavo di aver trovato la
pianta o la pianta per forza tirarla
addosso al tizio deve offrire una pianta
al tizio in segno di matrimonio ma che
cazzo succede
ma come è ovvio ma guardatevi
disinnescare una bomba non rimorchiare
un tizio ma quanto non senso sto gioco
il camicione ho preso la miccia
veramente
ragazzi non ho che non ho capito cosa
fai qui cestino alla bomba e nel cestino
quindi devo fare qualcosa con la bomba
nel cestino tipo fotocopiatrice e
l'unica cosa che mi sto fotocopiando le
chiappe non avevo dubbi lancio la pianta
nel cestino
ok ok questo questa aveva non ha senso
lo stesso ma più senso di tutte le
cagate che ho fatto fino adesso quindi
va ben primo round ragazzi che doveva
essere il primo però round 1 boom
sciacca l'aca con quale criterio danno i
nomi ai livelli da calciare io calcio io
calcio io no ho preso la palla e buttare
importa dalla al tizio caccia lui
dall'altra ma perché dovreste giocare
con un pallone che esplode spiegatemi
supermarket una merda vendono una merda
ho prestato una merce era comunque
un'ottima cosa da fare per disinnescare
una bomba ma con quale virilità me lo
stai dicendo zio la bomba qua in bella
vista ragazzi quindi devo tappare il
caso devo ammettere la schiuma non lo so
non era così gara non ci avevo proprio
dubbi un cimitero da grossi sono
impegnati per trovare location originali
e ragazzo che non ce n'è una uguale
all'altra c'è un mini zombie ma perché
hanno il braccio che ti si è staccato e
io e te lo butto qua dentro su capi che
è successo
oddio non ditemi che non ho visto quello
che ho appena visto da me e per chi non
l'ha capita meglio così c'è una barca
che va avanti va bene nostromo
buongiorno ma posso tirare ancora che ci
ancoriamo tutti e moriamo tutti quanti
ecco altro continua ad andare neanche
una bomba riesce a fermarla ci
mancherebbe casinari circuiti giusto non
era così niente hanno sbagliato tutto
non azzeccata una
devo prea ecco mi sembrava devo prendere
la porzione metto la pozione sulla merda
esploso eh vabbè dai ho pensato che in
qualche modo la merda potesse salvarci
la vita ma non ha funzionato ragazzi
doppiare a calci il tizio
questa era fottutamente geniale geniale
come ho fatto a non pensarci maledizione
cimitero col braccio ci devo fare
qualcosa per l'amor di dio non lo butto
più lì dentro
picchio la tomba no no no ok non ho
capito ma va bene
la bomba è quella salvagente il
salvagente sul genio tutto genio e vabbè
chissenefrega se salta tutti in aria di
sono salvo barca [ __ ] bastava questo
avevo fatto tre di fila
o c'è qualcosa qua mi chiama io non vedo
le cose lega che problema è se devo fare
questa palla spiegatevi devo darle al
portiere
l'ho lanciata fuori lo lancia ok era più
semplice di quanto pensassi ragazzi va
bene supermarket devo darle alla tizia
per forza non vedo altro a ma era quella
la bomba amica ma che ne so io se riesco
ad azzeccare sta benedetta cosa da fare
ce l'ho fatta a farne tre di fila però
non riuscirò mai prendo la bomba e la
metto sulla ancora mi sono bevuto la
bomba che cazzo è successo non ho capito
il bonus round non ho capito cosa ho
fatto non avrei mai chissà cosa devo
fare queste cose che non capisco
ragazzi io non capisco le cose bonus
spiegatemi cosa volete che io faccia in
quelle non ho capito anche l'altra volta
non ho capito cosa simile ma basta
fissare dentro le cose che palle
era era giusto è era questa la soluzione
geniale che non fatta ragazzi li ho
fatti tutti e tre incredibile non so con
quale tocco di genialità io sia riuscito
a farli tutti e tre ragazzi però ce l'ho
fatta con un ragazzo li ho finito il
secondo capitolo di mac pixel anche
questo super geniale prima ero io da
neonato poi io da bambino e adesso sono
io
normale
niente ragazzi continuerò nel prossimo
episodio spero che video vi sia piaciuto
e cosa che mi è piaciuto su un commento
è un mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e poi lo screzio nè se trovate
un senso a tutto questo magari lasciate
un altro mi piace visto che io non
capisco neanche di che cazzo stiamo
parlando e noi ci vediamo prossimo video
e speriamo anche che siamo intelligente
di questo però il tutto un dire bella
ragazza